ist das die lösung für den bob antrieb
für reisen mit überlichtgeschwindigkeit
ohne relativistische effekte ein
göttinger physiker hat sich mit der
physik der blasen beschäftigt und sie in
der theorie so konstruiert dass keine
negative masse mehr benötigt wird wir
könnten also diesen antrieb mit der
technologie mit den technologien bauen
die auf der erde existieren allerdings
gibt es noch einen haken pixum science
and future gibt es dreimal pro woche
spannendes seines videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los gings haben sich
willkommen das wettrennen in den
weltraum hat wieder begonnen das space
race 2.0 das diskutieren wir übrigens
hier auf dem kanal live mit dem esa
generaldirektor josef aschbacher der
astronautin kandidatin in setterich dem
europaabgeordneten liegt nach chinas von
den grünen und mir und ihr könnt live in
der zoom konferenz dabei sein
hierunter wie könnt ihr euch anmelden
der link es auch in der video
beschreibung oder im ersten angebot
einen kommentar die relativitätstheorie
hat uns unsere grenzen aufgezeigt und
die lauten zusammengefasst wir kommen
hier nicht weg das universum ist
eigentlich für jeden bewohner und jede
bewohnerin ein gefängnis ist unmöglich
darin größere distanzen zu überwinden
denn je schneller wir reißen desto
schwerer werden wir die zeit vergeht
langsamer wodurch wir in die zukunft
reisen und es wird immer mehr energie
benötigt um auch nur ein wenig zu
beschleunigen und mit heutigen antrieben
würde es jahre dauern und die benötigte
treibstoffmenge wäre unermesslich es
macht also überhaupt keinen sinn mit
konventionellen mitteln hohe
geschwindigkeiten zu erzielen
wir sehen es ja schon daran dass
entfernung im weltall in lichtjahren
angegeben werden ein lichtjahr ist die
entfernung die ein lichtstrahl in einem
jahr zurücklegt und schneller als ich
können wir uns nicht im raum bewegen und
selbst die lichtgeschwindigkeit wäre
eben nur mit einem nicht zu
bewältigenden aufwand zu erreichen
science fiction autoren haben eine
lösung für dieses problem gefunden den
warp antrieb schon 1948 schrieb chester
es geyer in seinem roman the flight to
the styling davon und wir alle kennen
den warp antrieb aus star trek von gene
roddenberry nicht selten liegen
science-fiction-autoren ja gar nicht so
falsch
bern hat die mondlandung vorausgesehen
und sein
und nautilus war atomgetriebenen das war
damals schon verrückt und liegen jetzt
vielleicht science fiction autoren und
autoren mit dem wort antrieb richtig die
idee dahinter stammt aus der physik wir
wissen dass sich das universum ausdehnt
und zwar der raum selbst für den gilt
das gesetz der unabänderlichen
lichtgeschwindigkeit nämlich nicht licht
aus entfernten galaxien kommt bei uns
rot verschob man also mit einer
niedrigen wellenlänge es wurde quasi
verlangsamt allerdings ist das de facto
nicht der fall
der raum in dem sich das sich bewegt hat
sich währenddessen viel mehr ausgedehnt
raum kann sich vollkommen unabhängig
bewegen und das auch schneller als das
licht die idee für den bob antrieb ist
deshalb simpel und genial dann verändern
wir doch einfach den raum und verkürzten
die strecke zwischen start und ziel wir
wollen ihn wir drücken ihnen zusammen
das ist die idee von warp antrieb das
raumschiff drückt den raum vorsicht
zusammen und dient ihnen hinter sich
wieder aus aber wie müsste ein solcher
antrieb gebaut sein da stoßen wir ganz
schnell ein paar kleine hindernisse so
erst mal hat der mexikanische physiker
miguel alko bier moya das durchgerechnet
allerdings war für seinen antrieb so
viel materie mit negativer masse nötig
dass es nicht so praktikabel war zehn
milliarden mal mehr solcher materie war
nötig als wir ganz normaler materie im
universum haben
inzwischen wurde an albers gleichungen
einiges verbessert und der bedarf konnte
deutlich reduziert werden
der us-forscher harry reid rechnete die
benötigte menge auf einige hundert
kilogramm herunter aber wofür wird
materie mit negativer masse benötigt und
was muss man sich darunter vorstellen
die idee ist dabei dass materie mit
positiver und materie mit negativer
masse gegenseitig mit dem raum
interagieren und in wie erwähnt vor dem
raumschiff komprimieren und dahinter
wieder expandieren normaler materie
würde dabei gravitation erzeugen und die
materie mit negativer masse anti
gravitation und wir wissen ja aus der
allgemeinen relativitätstheorie das
gravitation die raumzeit krümmt so weit
so gut es gibt nur einen kleinen haken
materie mit negativer masse die
existiert nämlich nicht im universum wie
kann sie also erzeugt werden tatsächlich
ist das einem forschungsteam bereits
gelungen ist hat ein
bose-einstein-kondensat
mit negativer masse erzeugt das entsteht
also dieses kondensat wenn man atome
eines gases annähernd auf den absoluten
nullpunkt von minus 273 15 grad celsius
heruntergekühlt dann befinden sie sich
in einem extremen aggregatzustand sie
bilden das bose-einstein-kondensat kurz
gk
das besondere daran ist diese atome
verhalten sich wie ein einziges atom und
diese atomkomplex schwingt dann
wellenartig im gleichtakt man kann in
dieser atomwolke kein einzelnes atom
mehr ausmachen
sie sind eins geworden und das
forschungsteam hat mit diesem fall denn
sagt etwas ziemlich verrücktes
angestellt und damit negative masse die
in der quantenphysik theoretisch zwar
möglich war
auch realität werden lassen wichtiges
vorwissen jedes teilchen hat einen spin
einen drehimpuls das ist je nach
teilchen unterschiedlich peter engels
und sein team an der washington state
university haben das
bose-einstein-kondensat aus rubidium
atomen app folgt danach mit lasern
durchgeschüttelt und damit ihren spin
geändert das verblüffende ergebnis die
rubidium atome verhielten sich jetzt so
als hätten sie eine negative masse das
bose einstein kondensat und findet sich
in diesem experiment in einer art falle
wenn sie geöffnet wird müsste es sich
eigentlich aus brighton jetzt war aber
genau das gegenteil der fall wenn wir
sie schubsten beschleunigten sie
rückwärts so der co autor michael fox
die forschung ist damit dem warp antrieb
ein ganzes stück näher gekommen und
jetzt aktuell hat sich die forschung den
bob antrieb vielleicht noch ein
stückchen genährt der göttinger physiker
dr erich lentz hat sich mit den blasen
beschäftigt und eine verblüffende lösung
gefunden bei ihm das gar keine negative
masse nötig er ist mit seinen
überlegungen in der lage vor blasen
ausschließlich mit positiver energie zu
erzeugen dazu die universität göttingen
in einem statement
bisherige forschungen über den über
licht schnellen transport auf der
grundlage von einsteins allgemeiner
relativitätstheorie erfordern riesige
mengen hypothetische teilchen und
materiezustände die exotische
physikalische eigenschaften wie eine
negative energie dichte aufweisen
erläutert die pressemitteilung der
universität göttingen
diese art von materie ist derzeit
entweder nicht zu finden oder kann nicht
in brauchbaren mengen herbst
es werden lenz hat dafür jetzt blasen
ernennt die solitude theoretisch
konstruiert die mit positiver energie
erzeugt werden dafür hat der physiker
sich bisherige forschungsarbeiten zum
web antrieb vorgenommen und sie
durchgerechnet und mängel aufgedeckt
dazu die universität lenz bemerkte dass
es noch nicht erforschte konfigurationen
der raumzeit krümmung gibt die in soli
toten organisiert sind und diese hätten
das potenzial das rätsel zu lösen und
gleichzeitig physikalisch realisierbar
zu sein
plenz leitete die einstein gleichung für
unerforschte solid ohne konfiguration ab
bei denen die schiffe vector komponenten
der raumzeit metrik einer hyper
bullischen beziehung gehorchen dabei
fand lenz heraus dass die veränderten
raumzeit geometrien auf eine weise
gebildet werden können die auch mit
konventionellen energiequellen
funktionieren weil das könnte
tatsächlich die lösung seien keine
negative masse wäre nötig um dem raum
hinter dem raumschiff wieder auszudehnen
und vor dem raumschiffe denn der raum
auch nicht mit materie zusammengedrückt
werden alles geschieht mit etwas das wir
bereits haben und beherrschen energie
lenz vergleicht die reisezeitung zum
nächstgelegenen sternensystem proxima
centauri mit der aktuellen technologie
dem chemischen raketenantrieb dauerte
diese reise bis zu 70.000 jahre mit
einem nuklear antrieb rund 100 jahre und
nur mit einem wort antrieb wäre die
reise in einem realistischen zeitraum
möglich sie würde vier jahre dauern
seine studie ist damit ein großer
schritt in zur tatsächlichen
realisierung des web antriebs diese
arbeit hat das problem des reisens mit
überlichtgeschwindigkeit einen schritt
weg von der theoretischen forschung in
der grundlagenphysik und näher an die
technik gebracht so lässt jetzt muss
allerdings noch ein problem gelöst
werden der immense energiebedarf der ist
nämlich dann doch so nicht realisierbar
dazu längst die energie die für diesen
antrieb bei lichtgeschwindigkeit für ein
raumschiff mit einem radius von 100
metern benötigt wird liegt in der
größenordnung des hundertfachen der
masse des planeten jupiter okay das ist
jetzt vielleicht etwas viel zu viel doch
lenz hat auch hier wege zumindest ins
auge gefasst glücklicherweise wurden in
früheren forschungen mehrere
energiesparende mechanismen
vorgeschlagen die die benötigte energie
potenziell
um fast 60 größenordnung senken könnte
oder es wird vielleicht eine kombination
von positiver energie und negativer
masse so langsam kommt die forschung bei
warp antrieb auf jeden fall in einen
bereich der es ermöglichen könnte
vielleicht schon bald die praktische
forschung für den warp antrieb zu
beginnen
aber auch was zurzeit in der raumfahrt
passiert ist hochspannend das space race
2.0
darüber spreche ich mit esa
generaldirektor josef aschbacher der
astronautin kandidatin ins attila eich
und dem europaabgeordneten niklas ninas
von den grünen seid live dabei hierauf
pixum schaut in den community patch für
weitere infos wir haben nämlich einige
fragen an euch die wir dann dort
behandeln und ihr könnt auch direkt in
der so konferenz dabei sein und
mitdiskutieren einfach hier klicken
anmelden und mitdiskutieren ich freue
mich auf euch am 18 märz um 19 uhr hier
auf pixel bis dann bleibt dran